ja schönen guten Abend in die Runde
freue mich auf einen
intimes Gespräch zunächst aber ganz kurz
an Frau Wagenknecht die Frage wir haben
das voll mitgekriegt sie mit Kopfhörer
im Ohr haben in der Maske sitzen noch an
der Fraktionssitzung teilgenommen sind
sie noch in der Linkspartei oder ist das
Geschichte nein natürlich bin ich noch
in der Linkspartei also wir haben ja in
der Fraktion auch noch mal klargestellt
dass es selbstverständlich die Freiheit
dass man Dates gibt und dieser Antrag
der etwas seltsam war der da eingebracht
wurde gegen mich wurde zurückgezogen
weil er keine entsprechende
Unterstützung hatte also insoweit das
ist nicht das Problem nur also ich finde
die ganze Debatte über meine Rede
offenbart ein bisschen dass wir
Schwierigkeiten haben in Deutschland
inzwischen rational zu diskutieren also
wenn ich mich im Bundestag hinstelle und
sage der Krieg in der Ukraine ist ein
Verbrechen aber trotzdem die
Wirtschaftssanktionen kritisiere weil
ich sage die richten sich mehr gegen uns
als gegen Russland dann wird gesagt das
sei eine wir haben sie vorhin gesagt wie
ein kr Sprecher oder eine pro russische
redet warum da wird ein Satz aus dem
Zusammenhang gerissen
lass uns folgendes machen wir hören
einmal alle gemeinsam kurz rein und
reißen auch nichts aus dem Zusammenhang
sondern haben sozusagen den Kontext
haben wir so gelassen wie er war und
danach reden wir gleich mal drüber
in Schlüsselindustrien werden
mit riesen schreibt das Handelsblatt
denn Herr Habeck in der Wirtschaft ist
das leider nicht so wie in der Politik
ein Minister der nichts mehr liefert
muss leider tatsächlich keine Insolvenz
anmelden sie sind das beste Beispiel
dafür wir haben wirklich die dümmste
Regierung in Europa wenn man sich das
anguckt aber nicht nur aber nicht nur
weil sie zur feige sind sich mit dem
krisengewinnern anzulegen das größte
Problem das größte Problem ist ihre
grandiose Idee einen beispiellosen
Wirtschaftsweg gegen unseren wichtigsten
Energielieferanten vom Zaun zu brechen
ja natürlich ist der Krieg in der
Ukraine ein Verbrechen ob es uns gefällt
oder nicht wenn wir ein Industrieland
bleiben wollen dann brauchen wir
russische Rohstoffe und leider auf
absehbare Zeit auch noch russische
Energie und deshalb schluss mit den
fatal Wirtschaftssanktionen verhandeln
wir in Russland mit Russland über eine
Wiederaufnahme der Gaslieferung wir sind
nicht unabhängig so und sie sagen ich
würde nicht mit Putin an einen Tisch
setzen und den fragen was müssen wir tun
damit das Öl wieder fließt und das Gas
wir müssen uns ja erstmal also wir sind
ja in einem Punkt einig am schlimmsten
Leiden zu Zeit die Menschen in der
Ukraine weil die sterben sie haben einen
schrecklichen Krieg und ich könnte ja
ihre Argumentation nachvollziehen wenn
wir mit diesen Wirtschaftssanktionen
ernsthaft einen Beitrag leisten würden
dass dieser Krieg aufhört dann könnte
man ja sagen okay wir halten das jetzt
noch zwei drei Monate durch dann ist das
schreckliche sterben beendet alles ist
gut ich sehe nicht dass die Sanktionen
irgendeinen relevanten Beitrag dazu
leisten im Gegenteil Putin hat höhere
Einnahmen als vorher Gastro macht
Rekordgewinne weil wir zwar viel weniger
importieren aber die Preise durch die
Sanktionen so nach oben gegangen sind
dass am Ende der russische Staat sogar
passiert und es gibt etwas nicht
dritten Jahresviertel 40% weniger
verdient als im zweiten Halbjahr so viel
verdient wie im ganzen letzten Jahr also
die haben doch enorme Gewinne gemacht
dass sie weniger verdienen und nicht
einfach die Party weitergegeben die
Sanktionen in Russland offensichtlich
nicht wirken und sie verkaufen schlecht
gemacht ja aber wir reden ja über die
die da sind und die Sanktionen die
verhängt wurden schlagen auf uns zurück
und zwar mit einer Brutalität die
wirklich für Millionen Menschen in
diesem Land bedeutet dass sie hat den
gaststahl gedreht ich verstehe das habe
ich schon in ihrer Rede nicht verstanden
ein Krieg von Deutschland wir hätten
eine Pipeline und die Bundesregierung
hat nicht erklärt dass dadurch keine Gas
mehr fließen darf im Gegenteil immer
geht jetzt davon aus dass man irgendwie
ohne russisches Gas klarkommen muss also
die Idee eines Krieges gegen Putin der
jetzt Öl abfackelt neben einer pipel
mittlerweile Gas abfackelt pardon neben
einer Pipeline weil er sie aus
politischen Gründen nicht mehr nach
Europa schicken will ja aber das führt
ja hat doch zwei Seiten also erstmal der
Begriff ist nicht meine Erfindung also
von Wirtschaftskrieg hat Spiegel
gesprochen hat habe gesprochen wir
können das auch anders nennen Sanktionen
oder wie auch immer also die haben
ganz kurz ganz kurz der Satz der Satz
ist es geht nicht um den Begriff
Wirtschaftskrieg es geht um den Kontext
das größte Problem als Vorwurf an die
Regierung ist ihre grandiose Idee einen
beispiellosen Wirtschaftskrieg gegen
unseren wichtigsten Energielieferanten
vom Zaun zu brechen das bedeutet die
deutsche Regierung hat einen Krieg vom
Zaun gebriechen und nicht putin hatte
die Ukraine angegriffen
Wirtschaftskrieg nicht von einem Krieg
mit Waffen den hat Putin gefunden
ich glaube das können wir erstmal als
Konsens in dieser Runde aber auf diesen
Krieg auf diesen Krieg hat die EU und
auch die deutsche Regierung mit massiven
Sanktionen geantwortet
das ist keine Zwangsläufigkeit also auf
dieser Welt wurden in den letzten 20
Jahren leider sehr sehr viele
völkerrechtswidrige Kriege geführt bei
anderen Ländern haben wir darauf nicht
mit Sanktionen geantwortet in dem Fall
haben wir im Moment in dem Falle haben
wir große Sanktionen verhängt und auf
diese Sanktionen reagiert jetzt Russland
da wo es uns weh tut nämlich bei dem
Gashahn und ich meine das geht ja immer
weiter die Spirale wir haben jetzt zum
Beispiel rosenheft enteignet Schwedt
wird beliefert wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
lange mit russischen Pipeline Gas und da
ist das nächste Problem wir haben keinen
Ersatz und das muss man auch sehen
andere Regierungen beteiligen sich daran
nicht also es ist nicht nur so dass
außerhalb der westlichen Welt kein
einziges Land sich an den Sanktionen
beteiligt sondern selbst innerhalb der
westlichen Welt in Europa Frankreich ist
im ersten Halbjahr zum größten Importeur
von russischem Flüssiggas aufgestiegen
ja natürlich also das stand ja in der
Handels im Handelsblatt in der Presse
Ungarn Tschechien importieren
selbstverständlich sehr russisches Öl
auch weiter russisches Gas Japan hat
jetzt noch mal deutlich gesagt sie
werden die Kooperation die
energiekooperation mit Russland
fortsetzen weil sie das eben brauchen
und unsere Regierung macht einen Schritt
nach dem nächsten der am Ende wie gesagt
nicht Putin schadet sondern wirklich die
Menschen hier in Deutschland arm macht
die Unternehmen bedroht vor allem
unseren industriellen Mittelstand und
das ist das finde ich sehr empfehlen
Ihre alternative ich verstehe ich kann
das nicht begreifen also es gibt einen
Krieg ein völkerrechtswidrigen Krieg den
sehen wir jeden Tag in der Ukraine es
gibt im Osten Europas
Befürchtungen dass das weitergeht das
ist ja der Grund warum man in Polen und
im Baltikum so aufgeregt ist und sie
sagen egal der kann das ruhig machen wir
machen nichts wir weil unsere Tage
ihre Antwort wir helfen doch nicht der
Ukraine indem wir unsere Wirtschaft und
unsere Industrie ruinieren also wir
helfen der Ukraine aktuell dadurch dass
wir Flüchtlinge aufnehmen wir helfen ihr
humanitär wir haben gesprochen dass wir
den Wiederaufbau unterstützen ich finde
dass wir auch viel mehr Initiativen aus
Europa brauchen für einen Friedensplan
für Diplomatie für Verhandlungen das
kommt aus anderen Enden der Welt ich
meine der türkische Präsident Erdogan
den ich nun wirklich für eine ziemlich
unerträgliche Figur halte der hat zum
Beispiel bei den Getreidelieferungen das
gemacht wo die Europäer gesagt haben das
geht nicht er hat verhandelt er hat
vermittelt und seitdem gibt es wieder
getreideschiffe die von der Ukraine
zu beenden also heute wird so haben wir
das gehört vorhin Putin vor die Presse
treten und wahrscheinlich noch mal eine
weitere Eskalation in diesem Konflikt
anheizen und ja wie wollen Sie
verhandeln mit jemandem der offenbar
nicht verhandeln will was wollen sie ihm
denn anbieten
zurzeit höre ich in der Presse ja das
hat man bei den Getreidelieferungen auch
gesagt und dann gab es ein
Verhandlungsergebnis heute hat oder
gestern der mexikanische Präsident
gesagt wir brauchen Friedensplan aus
verschiedenen Ecken der Welt kommt der
Druck deutsche machen
aber die Friedensplan kann noch nicht
darauf beruhen dass man sagt also wie
selensky zum Beispiel also bevor nicht
der letzte Russe auch von der Krim
verschwunden ist reden wir gar nicht
miteinander
um sie drehen das wirklich um sie sagen
jetzt wieder geht's geht das Schwarze
Peter zu zu dem Präsidenten dieses
angegriffenen Landes wenn der hier so
komische unrealistische Forderungen
stellt ist doch kein Wunder wenn der
arme Putin nicht einschlägt ich habe
noch ein zweites Problem
Menschen die dort sterben und das muss
beendet werden ja aber das liegt an wem
liegt das denn ja es liegt zunächst
daran dass die Ukraine von Russland
überfallen wurde natürlich das liegt nur
daran ja aber jetzt müssen wir doch
alles tun dass das beendet wird also
sich jetzt einfach hinzustellen und zu
sagen okay wir warten jetzt mal ab bis
die Russen dort abziehen weil sie
militärisch besiegt wurden das ist ja
schon eine schöne Vorstellung ist aber
nicht realistisch
ich habe mal das ist das einzige
mögliche auskommen ja aber Russland ist
eine Atommacht russland hat enorme
personelle und militärische Ressourcen
das ist kein Argument die USA sind auch
eine atommachte das ist immer das
ultimative Killerargument das ist eine
Atommacht das sind wir im Zweifel auch
das ist doch nicht das Argument und ich
habe ein anderes Problem mit diesen mit
dem wording ich ich habe ein Problem mit
diesem Wort Wirtschaftskrieg wir brechen
da diesen Wirtschaftskrieg vom Zaun und
wie sie das so sagen und intonieren und
sagen da gibt es diesen beispiellosen
Wirtschaftskrieg gegen unseren
wichtigsten Energielieferanten
ich finde das auch nicht schön wissen
Sie wie das klingt das klingt so wie
Putin hat jetzt diesen Krieg angezettelt
aber das was wir machen ist auch Krieg
und das ist genau diese pazifistische
Logik aus der das herauskommt nach dem
Motto das was die einmachen ist schlimm
aber was die anderen machen ist genauso
schlimm und das funktioniert an dem es
geht nicht genauso schlimm also wenn ich
Menschen töte weil ich Waffen Ansätze
heißt das eine andere Kategorie als wenn
ich ein Wirtschaftskrieg schwer trotzdem
weil er uns schadet also ich meine
einmal steht die Frage auch generell wo
haben Sanktionen schon mal einen
positiven Regimewechsel erreicht also es
gab massive Sanktionen gegen den Iran
massive Sanktionen gegen Syrien die
Bevölkerung hat gelitten die Regime sind
fester im Sattel als je zuvor also
einmal ist die Frage wie weit sie etwas
bewirken aber in dem konkreten Fall
jetzt ist es ja noch nicht mal so dass
sie vor allem in russlandschaden
anrichten sondern bei uns das stimmt ja
einfach nicht also das ist doch nicht
Wahr belegen Sie das doch also es gibt
einen brain drain aus Russland es gibt
viele es werden Autos gebraucht ohne
abs-formatikers haben kein ABS mehr und
sie haben kein Airbag mehr und das wiegt
auf dass in Deutschland Millionen Bäcker
jetzt vor der Schließung stehen das ganz
viele Industriebetriebe erleben werden
das ist doch Wahnsinn ich meine das hat
doch auf dem Krieg keinen Einfluss ob
die russischen Airbags haben
sie als jemand der die russische
Situation sehr gut kennt diese
Sanktionen wirken die ja treffen die
dieses russische Regie und die
Mathematik ist ganz einfach hier so die
GdP der so Einkommen von Russland
war so bevor dem Krieg
12 Mal kleiner als der Europäischen
Union so ich spreche nicht nur ich
spreche nicht über Großbritannien und
reinigten Staaten aber so russland hat
1,5 Trillionen US Dollar so pro Jahr so
verdient und Europäische Union 18
Trillionen und
die economische verbinden die war so
ziemlich
balanciert sozusagen so die
Handelsbilanz war ungefähr ausgeglichen
so wenn jetzt diese Funktion eingeführt
werden wenn dies anzünden sind so leidet
Russland russische Wirtschaft 12 Mal
größer starker als die deutsche
Wirtschaft
liegt aber daran dass wenn man in Europa
schon um Nullpunkt
0,5 Prozent so haushaltsverlust sprich
dann schon die die die gelbe Westen in
Frankreich und alle in Deutschland und
so alle sind ja sehr sehr sehr böse
Putin
kann das schon schaffen mit 6%
Verlust weil okay er hat seine
repressionapparatus im Platz er kann
gelöte so nieder ja niederschlagen und
so weiter und kann auch ganze fiktiv
gegen die Protest aber die sagen nicht
dass russische Wirtschaft nicht von den
Song leidet sie leidet und so zum
Beispiel die
Möglichkeiten für Puten neue Waffen zu
erstellen sind jetzt unheimlich begrenzt
weil sie kriegen keine chippen keine
keine Mikrochips alles was sie
eigentlich brauchen um etwas ein
bisschen kompliziertes als die
einfachste Artillerie zu erstellen wir
Waffen oder ähnliches sollte man ja auch
wirklich nicht hinliefern und das war ja
auch vorher schon nicht der Fall aber
wir sehen ja deutlich also es stimmt die
russische Wirtschaft das ist die
Schätzung vom IBF für dieses Jahr um 6%
schrumpfen das ist aber hauptsächlich
der Effekt wirklich der Monate wo die
Sanktionen eingeführt wurden sind ja
ganz viele Lieferketten gerissen da gab
es natürlich massive Probleme inzwischen
haben die Russen an vielen Punkten neue
Lieferketten erschlossen zum Beispiel
auch bei der Hochtechnologie wird es
natürlich mehr und mehr eine Hinwendung
zu China geben sie haben auch neue
Abnehmer erschlossen also das russische
Öl geht jetzt eben hauptsächlich nach
Südostasien und nicht mehr so sehr nach
Europa bei Gas ist das nicht ganz so
einfach weil man aus einer Flüssigkeit
aber wir haben sagen weg mit den
Sanktionen
ich finde dass diese Sanktion keinen
Beitrag dazu leisten diesen Krieg zu
beenden und uns aber in einer Weise
schädigen die völlig unverantwortlich
ist zweite Frage würden sie weiter
Waffen liefern in die Ukraine damit die
sich verteidigen kann ich glaube nicht
dass das diesen Krieg schneller beendet
das verlängert ihn finde dass wir jetzt
dringend einen Friedensplan und eine
friedenspinitiative würden sie
weitermachen liefern in Ukraine ja oder
nein ich halte die Lieferung schwerer
Waffen für einen großen Fehler dritte
Frage dritte Frage würden sie Nord
Stream 2 ans Netz nehmen aufmachen also
da muss man natürlich verhandeln also
wenn man die einfach so aufmachen wir
müssen darüber reden ob dann das Gas
wieder fließt auch
einmal verstehen also wenn Putin sagt
wenn ihr Nord Stream 2 aufmacht
dann schicke ich Gas durch was würden
Sie machen ja ich meine wenn wir jetzt
bescheuert wenn wir das nicht aufmachen
würden warum sollten wir das dann nicht
aufmachen wenn wenn das die einzige
Bedingung ist dafür dass wieder Gas
fließt dass wir diese Leitung öffnen ja
wieso denn da nicht aber wir müssen
gleichzeitig
beklagt wie viel Geld Putin mit der
Lieferung von Gas obwohl er weniger
geschickt hat dennoch verdient hat ich
wissen Sie was der Effekt wäre wenn
jetzt tatsächlich nur zum Teil öffnet
die Preise würden massiv sinken also wir
würden wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr
bezahlen Effekt wäre unsere Wirtschaft
würde weitergehen es wird überhaupt
keine Leidensdruck geben und in der
Ukraine würden könnte Putin in aller
Ruhe seinen Krieg durchziehen der
Leidensdruck in Deutschland ist groß
genug aktuell und er ist furchtbar und
ich meine wenn wir hier davon reden wo
Leute wir alle in der Runde sicherlich
dass am ehesten verkraften können
Menschen die ein normales Einkommen
haben die ein geringes Einkommen haben
die sind am verzweifeln wenn die ihre
Rechnungen sehen
dass ich das noch sage ich bin nicht der
Meinung dass wir jetzt einfach business
as usual machen und lassen den Krieg in
der Ukraine laufen ich bin immer der
Meinung dass man ihn schlagen Waffen
beendet sondern mit Diplomatie das ist
der Unterschied wir müssen beenden wie
geht das rufen Sie Putin an und sagen
Mensch ist lass mal reden ich habe kein
Gespräch
wir lassen das mit den Sanktionen wir
machen trotzdem zwei auf aber lass uns
ein bisschen reden was haben die
Waffenlieferung erreicht die Ukraine hat
jetzt in einem Punkt gewisse
Geländegewinne so das führt dazu dass
Russland das was es ja machen kann
nämlich eine Eskalation des Krieges
forciert das heißt es wird noch mehr
Leid geben es werden jetzt stärker
zivile Infrastrukturen angegriffen wir
sehen jetzt auch diese Eskalation dass
die versuchen in Johannes und Don jetzt
solche Volksabstimmungen zu inszenieren
dass sie zu Russland gehören das ist
alles eine Eskalation die ist immer
schwerer machen
das Heimat und andere Waffensysteme
anderem auch die berühmte Panzerhaubitze
2000 dazu geführt haben dass in einer
nennenswerten Zahl russische
Munitionsdepots in die Luft geflogen
sind dass die ukrainische armeem
möglicherweise gar keine großen
Waffenlieferungen mehr braucht weil sie
sich einfach nur an dem bedienen muss
was flüchten der Russen zurückgelassen
haben und ich habe gesehen und ich habe
keinen liefern müssen trotzdem ist es ja
doch wenn sie brauchen keine mehr aber
es ist doch raus aus dieser Logik also
was ich nicht verstehe ist der besten
liefert Waffen und Waffen und Waffen ja
wie soll denn das Ändern man braucht
doch ein Ausstiegsszenario es muss doch
irgendwie zu Ende gehen dieser kriege
den Krieg alles und Daten sollen weg und
das ist das einzige Möglichkeit es doch
es ist und Ukraine hat das schon
bewiesen so mit mit dem
Offensive
Militär ist anders ich meine auch der
Generalinspektor der Bundeswehr hat
davor gewarnt jetzt in Euphorie
auszubrechen wegen der Geländegewinne
russland hat leider noch sehr viele sehr
viel Potenzial alles ja nicht eingesetzt
haben und ich meine das von der
äußersten Rechten in Russland inzwischen
offen mit Atomwaffen Einsätzen gedroht
wird das ist grauenvoll und ich meine
ich möchte nicht dass das jemals dazu
kommt aber deswegen muss man versuchen
diesen Krieg zu deeskalieren und zurzeit
hat der Westen weniger als andere Länder
wie gesagt wenn ein der Präsident von
Mexiko sogar sich also in der Lage sieht
da etwas vorzulegen hat das gemacht
bevor er gestürzt wurde also es gab
zaghafte Vorstöße aber von der deutschen
Regierung war wenig zu hören
bevor die anderen beiden gesehen in der
Runde rutschen auch schon hungrig auf
dem Stuhl hinterher und haben gleich
ganz viel zu sagen ich habe eine Sache
noch sie sagten gerade wir müssen raus
aus dieser Logik sie wissen ich schätze
sie ich schätze vor allen Dingen ihre
publizistische Arbeit sehr und
bediene mich auch immer wieder gerne an
Fakten die sie teilweise veröffentlichen
alles gut und wir sind uns auch alle
einig dass die Konzentration von Waffen
in einer solchen Menge auf einem so
kleinen Raum durchaus gefährlich sein
kann und wir alle wissen nicht ob wir
nicht morgen in den Mündung genau der
Knarre gucken die wir heute in Ukraine
liefern dafür gibt es unzählige
Beispiele und da bin ich auch völlig bei
Ihnen und das bestreitet auch niemand
ich habe aber ein Problem mit dem Satz
wir müssen raus aus dieser Logik ihre
Logik sie haben dieser Tage erobert
Habeck in derselben Rede attackiert und
haben folgendes zu ihm gesagt es mag ja
sein dass ihnen Robert Habeck auch egal
ist was ihre deutschen Wähler denken und
jetzt kommt's aber sie haben nicht das
Recht Millionen Menschen die sie
mehrheitlich nicht gewählt haben ihren
bescheidenen Wohlstand und ihre Zukunft
zu zerstören das ist eine krasse Umkehr
von Logik es gibt nur einen Menschen der
Wohlstand und Zukunft zerstört und der
sitzt dem Kreml und heißt Vladimir Putin
aber ich kann Robert Habeck aber Putin
hat doch nicht gemacht in Deutschland
den wohl zerstören also ich meine das
ist doch wirklich jetzt etwas absurd
also dass wir diese Sachen
sie wissen doch sie wissen doch ganz
genau dass an deutscher
Wirtschaftsminister nicht eine solche
Entscheidung trifft Robert
Habeck hat gesagt zum Beispiel dass wir
das Öl im barco machen das andere Länder
nicht machen das ist eine Entscheidung
der deutschen Regierung das war das
falsch ja natürlich ist es falsch weil
wir kein Ersatz haben ich meine ich wäre
ja auch dafür
da bin ich aber mal gespannt wenn die in
die druschperleitung abklemmen was sehr
wahrscheinlich jetzt stattfinden wird
nachdem man rosenheft enteignet hat hat
man keinen Ersatz es gibt eine Leitung
nach Rostock und jeder weiß die wird
nicht den Ersatz liefern da hängen
tausende Arbeitsplätze dran da hängt im
Grunde die die Energieversorgung fast
das ganze im Osten und die fragen Sie
keinen Ersatz also das ist eigentlich
das Kernproblem ich hätte doch gar
nichts dagegen wenn wir jetzt viele
verschiedene Lieferanten hätten wo man
sagen kann okay also wir haben vorher 55
Prozent aus Russland bezogen wir würden
zu einer ähnlichen Preislage aus vielen
anderen Ländern beziehen können dann
könnte man das stärker diversifizieren
ja gut aber das haben kein Ersatz wir
haben keine Möglichkeit preiswerte
Energie woanders zu bekommen sie haben
in dieser Sendung und dann dürfen sie
sofort so oft und auch oft überzeugend
moralisch argumentiert sie sind jemand
der immer nicht nur vorgibt sondern bei
dem ich spüre da ist jemand der hat
Werte der hat ein Koordinatensystem dem
sind Dinge wichtig und sitzen Sie hier
und sagen also wenn wir das Öl woanders
herkriegen gar kein Problem aber das Gas
woanders her kriegen gar kein Problem
was ist mit diesem Krieg was ist mit
diesem Mann der versucht eine
Nachkriegsordnung etwas was seit 1945
genauso da steht grundsätzlich in
Zweifel zu ziehen was ist jemand mit
jemandem der der vorgibt sozusagen dass
die NATO angeblich eine Bedrohung ist
obwohl er nur 1500 Kilometer Grenze mit
der NATO hat und jetzt die Ukraine
überfällt und dann noch mehr an die NATO
heranrückt verstehen Sie diese ganze
Logik ist vollkommen krude und dieser
Krieg ist offensichtlich schon seit 2007
nicht nur Sicherheitskonferenz in
irgendeiner Form angelegt da hat sie
plötzlich das kann man im Buch von Herrn
Wollkopf noch mal sehr gut nachlesen da
hat sich dieser Ton gegenüber Europa
fundamental verändert und ich frage sie
an dem Punkt wenn sie hören dass die AFD
klatscht wenn sie so Reden im Bundestag
eine ganz kurz wenn sie mitkriegen wie
im Kreml die Sektkorken knallen wenn
Leute wie sie so reden im Deutschen
Bundestag müssen sie da nicht sagen es
hat eine gewisse Tragik dass das erste
Opfer russischer Propaganda ausgerechnet
eine kluge Frau wie sie ist und das
zweite Opfer gleichermaßen ist jemand
wie krupala sie beide sind sozusagen das
perfekte Opfer russischer Propaganda
also ich glaube nicht dass es einmal die
Sektkorken knallen wenn im Bundestag der
Ukraine Krieg als Verbrechen bezeichnet
wird so also insoweit ist das einfach
billig und ich glaube dass die
Sektkorken eher dort knallen wenn die
Einnahmen so weiter steigen wie jetzt
und wir kommen immer wieder zu dem
gleichen Buchstaben die Einnahme noch
viel viel weiter nein also wir haben ja
vorhin darüber geredet
wir hatten im letzten Jahr zwar auch
schon einen höheren Gaspreis das hatte
mit Corona und anderen Dingen zu tun
aber wir hatten natürlich nie eine
solche Explosion das ist und genauso
beim Ölpreis die Folge der Sanktionen
und wir kommen immer wieder zu dem
gleichen Punkt wir helfen der Ukraine
nicht wenn wir unser industrielles
Rückraum brechen unseren industriellen
Mittelstand zu schaffen das ist ein
Wahnsinn und das ist unverantwortlich
und dafür ist diese Regierung sie können
doch nicht sagen wir helfen der Ukraine
nicht wenn wir unser industrielles
Rückgrat brechen die der Zusammenhang
ist doch ein völlig anderer der
Zusammenhang ist doch wir helfen der
Ukraine wenn wir ihr dabei helfen sich
gegen Russland zu wehren das ist der
Punkt helfen die Arbeit auch nicht wenn
wir uns selber schaden wir Schaden uns
das finde ich muss mal begreifen aber
ich finde dass diese Regierung so viel
mehr wenn wir Putin gewähren lassen
Entschuldigung
lassen es geht um demokratische Werte
und es geht um keine westlichen Werte
sie haben nämlich in der Regierung
weiter ja dann sozusagen der Regierung
unterstellt man würde sich jetzt in
Amerika bedienen make America great
again haben Sie gesagt haben sich bei
Herrn Fassade Ergebnis dieser Sanktionen
aber das impliziert ja das ist irgendwie
um eine eine Verschwörung gegen Russland
und eigentlich will man doch wieder den
besten jetzt in den Vordergrund rücken
und deswegen muss das deutsche Volk
Leiden das haben sie gesagt es ist ja
völlig völlig in Ordnung als ganz
prominente Oppositionspolitikerin das
ist nötig die Regierung anzugreifen kann
man ganz viele Sachen machen man kann
die gasumlage Schuldenbremse gibt 1000
Punkte aber sie haben eine an einem Wert
gerührt und das ist etwas was ja auch
ihre Partei ihnen so übel genommen hat
darüber haben
dass die Regierung keinen Plan hat sie
machen
zum Minister 1900
1943 Völkerrecht das ist genau das was
man dort nachlesen kann und kluge Leute
können auch den Paragrafen wobei sie
wissen dass alles viel viel besser als
ich das war doch eine der Lehren dass
das so nicht wieder stattfindet und wir
sind geradezu verpflichtet an dem Land
das überfallen wird zu helfen das ist
auch noch kein Kriegseintritt sondern
haben wir einfach nur an dem Land dabei
geholfen sich zu verteilen auf der
ganzen Welt zu handhaben wer hilft dem
jemenien also ich meine das ist zum
Beispiel auch ein Zeichen für diese
Doppelmoral aserbaidschan hat vor zwei
Jahren ein völkerrechtswidrige Krieg
gegen Armenien geführt hat seine Grenzen
völkerrechtswidrig ausgedehnt hat sogar
vor einigen Tagen noch mal militärisch
gegen armenien ist vorgegangen gegen
Armenien und das wird jetzt unser neuer
gaskumpel also da gibt es jetzt von der
Leyen war da und hat jetzt gerade noch
mal einen neuen Vertrag gemacht wir
verdoppeln die so der Kanzler fährt
jetzt nach in die Vereinigten Arabischen
Emirate die sind an dem furchtbaren
Krieg im Jemen mit Saudi-Arabien
beteiligt seit Jahren wird dort gebombt
werden Menschenleben zerstört es ist
also grauenvoll
Öl besorgen für dieses Land also ich
meine das ist doch eine Widerspruch in
Russland sahen wir dürfen nichts mehr
kaufen weil wir sind ja ganz moralisch
und bei allen anderen Kriegen dieser
Welt von den us-kriegen gar nicht zu
reden da wird also drüber hinweggegangen
das zeigt doch dass hier keine Moral
irgendwie
alle argumentieren Frau Wagenknecht und
wenn sie sagen zu Recht auch bemängel
haben sie ja recht sie sagen da haben
wir unsere doppelten Standards und es
ist eine seltsame Doppelmoral wenn wir
sozusagen das eine zulassen und beim
anderen dann aber aufschreien was ist
das dann was sie vorschlagen also weil
ich finde dort nichts tun tun wir jetzt
auch hier nichts ist das dann wenn sie
mit Moral argumentieren ist was ist das
dann das ist ja dann nicht Doppelmoral
ist das der moralisch verkommen oder was
ist das nein ich habe gesagt dass wir
zum Beispiel ich habe mich immer dafür
eingesetzt dass wenn Kriegsgebiete keine
Waffen liefern ich meine wäre ich ja
schon mal froh wenn wir zum Beispiel
auch den Jemen kriegt wenn wir keine
Parteien die daran beteiligt sind mit
Waffen beliefern würden aber Deutschland
kann es sich nicht leisten jetzt
sozusagen nur noch Rohstoffe und Energie
in Lupen rein Demokratien zu kaufen also
ich meine das wäre schön und wir alle
wünschen uns eine Welt die anders ist
als die heutige aber das wäre einfach
nur unser wirtschaftliches Ende und
deswegen glaube ich muss man natürlich
auch mit einem gewissen Maß an
Pragmatismus Vorgehen was nicht heißt
dass wir Kriege unterstützen wie gesagt
ich finde es ein schäbig wenn die
deutsche Waffenindustrie und das tut sie
ein sehr vielen Kriegen dieser Welt noch
mitverdient weil sie dafür hinstellen
und das ist das ist ein Skandal also das
müsste man sofort einstellen wenn man
jetzt so moralische Außenpolitik machen
will und ich finde auch sonst können wir
sicherlich noch einiges tun um
tatsächlich für die Werte die wir ja
immer auf unsere Fahne schreiben auch
etwas
leben sie eben sehr widersprüchlich also
zum Beispiel werden wir die
Waffenexporte hätte man ja längst
verbieten können in viele Regionen
dieser Welt wo ganz klar ist dass wir
damit auch Konflikte anheizen aber bei
den Sanktionen ist es eben anders diese
Sanktionen Schaden uns vor allem und sie
haben natürlich Profiteure also die
US-Wirtschaft profitiert das kann man ja
ohne Verschwörungstheorie einfach
feststellen sie profitieren weil die
fracking-industrie jetzt boomt sie
profitieren auf einmal haben sie nicht
provoziert sondern auch da wieder ist
die Ursache der 24 Februar also nein
also wie gesagt auf andere Kriege
unterstellt
und ich finde dass die Bundesregierung
etwas mehr Durchblick haben sollte weil
andere Regierungen sehen mehr darauf was
ihrem Land nützt und was ihrem Land
nicht aber ist doch ein EU embargo zum
Beispiel und noch mal Gas hat ja obwohl
das hier gefordert wurde wurde immer
weiter bezogen bis Russland den Hahn
abgedreht hat deswegen verstehe ich auch
diese nordstream 2 Debatte immer gar
nicht also man soll Putin doch den
Gefallen tun auf seine
sein Flehen dass man das sozusagen
anerkennt diese nord-szene 2 Pipeline
die in Deutschland und in den
Vereinigten Staaten und in Europa so
immer schon umstritten war um was zu
machen also da geht dann Gas durch von
Russland während er weil
die Frage war ja vorhin wenn sie liefern
würden sollten wir dann aufmachen und
dann habe ich gesagt ja natürlich wenn
sie liefern würden müssen wir aufmachen
weil wir brauchen das Gas wenn sie nicht
liefern ja gut dann bringt es auch
nichts die Leitung zu öffnen aber weil
sie sagen das sind EU-Sanktionen die
einzelnen Länder der EU reagieren sehr
unterschiedlich vorhin schon gesagt
einige beteiligen sich einige beteiligen
sich gar nicht das groß und nicht die
großen Nationen sind sich da ziemlich
einig betroffen die Länder sind ich
meine Spanien Portugal haben andere
Gaslieferungen wir haben keine Pipelines
aus Russland also da man die müssen sich
nicht beteiligen es ist vor allem
Deutschland dass dadurch den größten
Schaden hat und deswegen muss man immer
wieder sagen ich meine wir haben ja in
den vergangenen Jahren ein
wohlstandsmodell in Deutschland gehabt
das schon glaube ich wo viele Leute auch
überzeugt sind dass das sehr viel mehr
Wohlstand erzeugt hat in manchen anderen
Ländern das hing daran dass wir eine
starke Industrie haben und einen starken
industriellen Mittelstand das haben
viele Länder nicht das muss man immer
wieder sagen und das gefährden wir